as governor sisalek has mentioned we
will see an
increase in covid cases this coming week
after
the holiday season unfortunately the
number of coveted cases has increased
significantly as of late
reporter madison kimbrough breaks down
the numbers for us and she joins us live
in the newsroom
with the latest on this madison
yes to put it bluntly it's just not
looking good for the state of nevada in
particular clark county now take a look
today the southern nevada health
district announced that there are over
13
hundred new cases of kova 19 bringing
the total in clark county to over 200
thousand
as a state nevada has almost 1500 new
coveted 19 cases
bringing the total to 261 573
for the entire state and there have been
18 coveted 19 deaths in the state
in the past 24 hours this comes a day
after a record high of 63 deaths
were reported data shows that 14 of
nevada's 18 deaths were reported right
here
in clark county and it's important to
remember that the state of nevada is no
longer on a tier
system so what does that mean within the
general public those
70 years of age or older are the main
priority to get vaccinated
the cdc reports that over 83 thousand
doses of the coven 19 vaccine
have been administered in the state so
far
and now we've gotten you know several
calls to our newsroom about where to
find information
regarding the vaccine and where to go to
get it so let me walk you through
right now we're going to start on the
home page of 8newsnow.com right here
you're going to see our top five stories
the story that you want to go to
is this one right here vaccine
information
when and where you can expect to expect
to receive the covet 19 vaccine
click on this story right here once it
takes you to the main
page of this story you're going to have
all the information you need
you're going to scroll and you will see
links associated
to whatever vaccination system that you
need to go to so for instance right here
front line workers essential workforce
general population of 70 years
or older you're going to click right
here as we scroll down you're going to
see more links and whatever applies to
you
that is where you are going to click
we've made it really simple for you so
once again
it's going to be on our home page and
it's going to be part of our top five
stories
it's vaccine information when and where
you can expect to receive the coven 19
vaccine
one other reminder we want to say is if
forever
any reason that you have for not being
able to find
this story right here on our home page
you can always go to the search bar
it's a picture right here an image of a
magnifying glass click
on that and you can put vaccine
information and it should take you
straight to the site and the area that
you need to go to
all right sasha sending it back to you